let's say that we have a random variable
x maybe it represents the height of a
randomly selected person walking out of
the mall or something like that and
right over here we have its probability
distribution
and i've drawn it as a bell curve as a
normal distribution right over here but
it could have many other distributions
but for for the visualization's sake
it's a normal one in this example and
i've also drawn the mean of this
distribution right over here and i've
also drawn one standard deviation above
the mean and one standard deviation
below the mean
what we're going to do in this video is
think about how does this distribution
and in particular how does the mean and
the standard deviation
get affected if we were to
add to this random variable or if we
were to scale this random variable
so let's first think about what would
happen if we have another random
variable which is equal to let's call
this random variable y
which is equal to
whatever the random variable x is
and we're going to add a constant
so let's say we add
so we're going to add some constant here
i'll do a lowercase k this is not a
random variable this is a constant it
could be the number 10. so if these are
random heights of people walking out of
the mall well you're just going to add
10 inches to their height for some
reason maybe you want to figure out well
the distribution of people's heights
with with helmets on or or plumed hats
or whatever it might be
how would that affect how would the mean
of y and the standard deviation of y
relate to x
so we could visualize that so
what the distribution of y would look
like so instead of this instead of the
center of the distribution instead of
the mean here being right at this point
it's going to be shifted up by k in fact
we can shift
the entire distribution would be shifted
to the right
by k
in this example and maybe k is quite
large maybe it looks something like
that
this is my distribution
for my random
variable y here
and you can see that the distribution
has just shifted to the right by k
so we have moved to the right
by k we would have moved to the left if
k was negative or if we were subtracting
k and so this clearly changes the mean
the mean is going to now be k larger so
we can write that down we can say that
the mean of our random variable
y
is equal to
the mean of x
the mean
of x of our random variable x plus k
plus k
you see that right over here
but has the standard deviation changed
well remember standard deviation is a
way of measuring typical spread from the
mean and that won't change so
in for a random variable x
this is this length right over here is
one standard deviation
well that's also going to be the same as
one standard deviation here this is one
standard deviation here this is going to
be the same
as our standard deviation for our random
variable
y
and so we can say
the standard deviation of
y of our random variable y is equal to
the standard deviation of our random
variable x
so if you if you just add to a random
variable it would change the mean but
not the standard deviation you see it
visually here
now what if you were to scale a random
variable so what if i have another
random variable i don't know let's call
it z
and let's say z is equal to some
constant
some constant times x
and so remember this isn't the k is not
a random variable it's just going to be
a number it could be say the number 2.
let's think about what would happen
so let me redraw
the distribution for our random variable
x
so let's see if k were 2 what would
happen is is with this distribution
would be scaled out it would be
stretched out by two and since the area
always has to be one it would actually
be flattened down by a scale of two as
well so it still has the same area
so i can do that with my little drawing
tool here let me try to first i'm going
to stretch it out
by
oops first actually i'll make it shorter
by a factor of two
but more importantly it is going to be
stretched out
by a factor of 2. so let me align the
axes here so that we can appreciate this
so it's going to look something like
this
it's going to look something like this
when you scale the random variable
this is what the distribution of our
random variable z is going to look like
i'll do the disease color so that it's
clear
and so you can see two things one the
mean for sure shifted the mean it's the
mean here for sure got pushed out it
definitely got scaled up
but also we see that the standard
deviations got scaled that the standard
deviation right over here of z
that this is a this has been scaled it
actually turns out that it's been scaled
by a factor of k
so this is going to be equal to k
times the standard deviation of our
random variable x and it turns out that
our mean right over here
so let me write that too that our mean
of our random variable z
is going to be equal to that's also
going to be scaled up
times or it's going to be k times the
mean
of our random variable x
so the big takeaways here
if you
have one random variable that's
constructed by adding a constant to
another random variable it's going to
shift the mean by that constant but it's
not going to affect the standard
deviation
if you try to scale if you multiply one
random variable to get another one by
some constant then that's going to
affect both the standard deviation it's
going to scale that and it's going to
affect the mean